today on the matt well show chris pratt
has been trending on social media
all week thanks in large part to
leftists who think he might be a trump
supporter because he didn't attend
a biden fundraiser with other marvel
actors this is how
the modern witch hunt works we'll talk
about that also five headlines including
biden finally responding to the hunter
biden scandal
sort of and the city of miami holds a
press conference because people are
offended by a face mask worn by a miami
police officer
this was uh there was a press conference
was necessary for this issue finally in
our daily cancellation i will cancel
birthdays all of that coming up but
first i want to tell you about an
exciting new sponsor mack weldon
you know i'll tell you what i love most
about mack weldon the clothes fit great
they're comfortable
they look great it can be really hard to
get all three of those in one item of
clothing but with mac weldon
you can you know the new normal uniform
has a lot of us searching our closets
and drawers
for men's essentials that aren't there
instead of the usual business casual
button ups and jeans it's
soft knit polos tees joggers active
shorts whatever men's basics you need
though
mack weldon has you covered with
unmatched comfort and fit socks shirts
hoodies underwear polos
active shorts mack weldon promises
comfort and a consistent fit and there's
a lot of versatility to mac welding
clothing they look great
they feel great from working out going
out going to work
uh or if you're out on a date whatever
it is mac weldon is
for everyday life you you have to be in
your clothes all day
you know especially when you're out in
public it's advised to keep them on
and that means they should be
comfortable and they should be stylish
too so for 20
off your first order visit macweldon.com
walsh enter promo code walsh that's mac
weldon.com
walsh promo code walsh for 20 off
all right well you know if you had the
misfortune of living in
17th century colonial massachusetts uh
it would not have taken much for you to
be labeled a witch
those suspected of witchcraft and
executed for it didn't need to be seen
flying through the air in a broom
some were burned simply for associating
with others
who were suspected of being witches some
for having certain physical
traits thought to be marks of witchery
your age your gender your social class
your family all of these were thought to
be
passive clues potentially indicating
that you are a witch
or possibly a witch or which adjacent
now we would like to think that
things are different now in our
enlightened times but
humans are humans and the witch trials
were born from the very human tendency
to invent
new enemies in our heads and then to
suddenly find them everywhere we turn
we have many such boogeymen in our
culture
they're they're they're more likely to
be punished with mockery and alienation
rather than incineration but
as we've seen the latter option
incineration hasn't been taken off the
table entirely especially
recently uh the actor chris pratt has
experienced
all of this this week and not for the
first time uh experiencing the wrath of
the modern witch hunters
his suspected crime being a christian a
conservative and worst of all
a trump voter now while pratt is a
professed christian
and does seem to perhaps be more
politically conservative than the
average hollywood celebrity
which is sort of like calling him
cleaner than the average dumpster cat
there's no reason to actually think that
chris pratt supports trump there's even
less reason to care if he does or
doesn't
but the witch hunters on the left cannot
tolerate dissent even theoretically
and especially not from someone in a
profession
or demographic group of which they have
claimed claimed ownership
and that is why pratt has been trending
on social media all week for days now
not because leftists are outraged by
things that he has said or beliefs he
has professed which would be bad enough
if that were the reason but because of
their suspicions about beliefs he might
hold
as twitter describes it you can see
there here on their trending section
uh the chris chris pratt controversy
that has sparked over 260 000 tweets
is focused on quote his alleged
political and religious beliefs
now this seems to have started with news
that some avenger actors are taking part
in a joe biden
virtual fundraiser cringily titled
voters assemble
marvel luminaries like chris evans
scarlett johansson mark ruffalo don
cheadle paul rudd
zoe seldonna all volunteered for the
noble clause
but a few actors were missing from the
biden fundraiser roster
and this fact became cause for great
concern now it was apparently decided
that some of the missing superheroes
should be given an excused absence
because they're not from this country
like the guy who plays spider-man
spider-man's off the hook
but chris pratt has no such alibi
and this raised suspicion as an article
in the av club put it quote
the fundraiser will feature a trivia
game and q a which we hope will at least
be partially dedicated to asking about
every single member of the avengers
who isn't there a good number of them
aren't from the u.s so we can't expect
them to clean up our mess in this dumb
country
but this is the second one of these
biden fundraiser reunion things
that chris pratt has missed out on we
theorized last time that he's either a
republican
or just wants everyone to get along and
can't endorse anyone since he's all
buff and churchy now but we'll have to
wait and see what happens if the biden
campaign organizes an everwood reunion
from there it was off to the races with
great numbers of people
attacking chris pratt for what they
assume his political views
probably are and the circumstantial
evidence that pratt secretly wears maga
hats in his spare time
goes beyond his absence at a biden
fundraiser we should note he also uh
he also attends according to leftist
critics including fellow actor ellen
page
uh in anti-lgbt church
so that's a red flag plus as vanity fair
points out
quote pratt's personal life has also led
to speculation about his politics
last year uh pratt married catherine
schwarzenegger daughter of
daughter of arnold schwarzenegger a
long-time republican
though the article points out that
catherine publicly supports biden
so at least someone in the pratt
household isn't the white supremacist
that's good
other media outlets have have weighed in
now listen to this newsweek
ran a fact check analyzing the claims
that pratt is quote allegedly a
republican and trump supporter
the article sifts through all the clues
you know looking at all the different
evidence eventually landing on the
verdict of unknown
newsweek says we cannot verify if pratt
is a trump supporter because he hasn't
confirmed it
the hollywood actor has not shown any
support publicly for the president for
the president or his democratic
challenger joe biden
but unknown isn't good enough
especially when pratt as some on twitter
have pointed out
follows uh notorious nazis like ben
shapiro and
dan crenshaw if pratt wants to absolve
himself of his assumed thought crimes
he has to come out and publicly support
biden and denounce trump
anything less will be insufficient
now to the credit many of pratt's
castmates have come to his defense
uh against the slobbering mindless
hordes
but they've come in for harsh criticism
because of that especially zoe saldana
who uh
was attacked with racial slurs by the
racially tolerant left
one person calling her a nasty biracial
woman
another saying their quote tired of
defending your crack-a-loving ass
adding of course shut up along with many
other comments that i i just can't read
out loud all of this again
it cannot be emphasized enough merely
because of political views
that the man might hold so gone are the
days when people can be viciously
attacked
for the opinions they express well those
days are still here but we're now living
in a time
when you could be attacked for opinions
you did not express
silence is violence as the slogan goes
and the people who say that
really mean it now i don't say this just
because i'm a conservative it really is
true that only one side of the
ideological divide
behaves this way and that's at least
partially a reflection of just how
dominant and mainstream leftism is
it still positions itself of course as
the counterculture but it isn't
it is the culture and now having won
every major battle and seized nearly all
of the cultural power
it can concern itself with issues like
chris pratt's theoretical political
leanings
only the dominant culture and the
dominant cultural narrative can
demand allegiance to this extent counter
culture movements aren't usually the
ones conducting witch hunts
and this is what makes all the talk
about resistance from the left so absurd
what are you resisting what is the
resistance resisting
you own everything just this week sony
became the latest of dozens and dozens
of billion dollar corporations
to endorse black lives matter and this
only a few days after was announced
that one of the marxist co-founders of
blm has inked a major deal with warner
brothers
what type of counter-culture movement
has billion-dollar sponsors
and contracts with major hollywood
studios a fraudulent one
that's what type the left dresses up in
costumes the costume of outsiders and
radicals and complains about alleged
depression
and then they charge out into the street
to fight enemies they've already
defeated
and monsters that don't exist so instead
they burn down a cvs
steal a few arm loads of shoes call it a
day go home
tweet about why a marvel actor is
persecuting them by not saying anything
at all
this is the behavior of the comfortable
the victorious
and the board and that's what leftism is
but what it is not certainly most of all
is counter culture
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you know we think of life insurance
as this uh scary
and overwhelming thing but it doesn't
have to be you know and and we talk
about
it is halloween this month and and so i
think policy genius would like to mark
the occasion by
making something a little bit less scary
we've got enough scary things in our
lives
uh life insurance shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
but policy genius just makes it really
easy they combine a cutting edge
insurance marketplace with help from
licensed experts
to save you time and money and it's all
about ease it's all about
this is what they're talking about you
just go to policy genius you could save
up
to 50 or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a
decade those savings really start to add
up so you think 50
already sounds like a good deal think
about how long you're gonna have the
life insurance policy
here's how it works first you head to
palsygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need and
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price
um policy genius will will will compare
policies
starting as little as one dollar a day
and they're gonna look at all these
policies
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork all the
red tape
and that's it on your end they're doing
everything all you got to do
just take the initiative go to
policygenius.com so if you need life
insurance head to policygenius.com right
now to get started
you could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right
well joe biden has for the first time
answered a question about the
hunter biden email sort of it's amazing
well not amazing but
it should be amazing that he was able to
go this long without being forced to
answer
about this and um and he was finally
asked about it
during a an interview with a local
reporter in wisconsin
it wasn't even a of course if he was on
cnn or msnbc
this question would not have come up but
he was on a local news channel wisconsin
and here's how that went so wisconsin's
republican senator
ron johnson put out a statement on
homeland security letterhead
saying hunter biden together with other
biden family members profited off the
biden name is there any legitimacy
to senator johnson's claims none
whatsoever
this is the same garbage rudy giuliani
trump's
henchmen it's the last its effort in
this desperate campaign to smear me and
my family
even the man who served with him on that
committee the former
nominee for the republican party said
there's no basis to this
and you know and all and the vast
majority of the intelligence people have
come out and said
there's no basis at all ron should be
ashamed of himself
now notice what he doesn't say he
doesn't say that the emails are a
fabrication doesn't even mention the
emails
he doesn't say that their fabrication
doesn't say they're fake it doesn't say
the laptop story is a hoax
um he doesn't say that he denies okay he
doesn't confirm it explicitly
but he doesn't say if these were a hoax
and just made up
i mean if someone if if rudy giuliani or
or whoever
is making this up and that is the claim
you still get from the left
and the media if that were the case then
joe biden would say so he would come out
and say this is totally made up and
ridiculous
it doesn't say that um
and you know it it's it's just not
credible then
at this point to say that it's a hoax or
russian disinformation
when even joe biden himself is not
saying that
all right uh number two a video has been
making the rounds online it apparently
shows a city official
finding a restaurant owner in new york
for the crime of no he wasn't
he wasn't like having indoor diners when
he wasn't supposed to hurt
no he just he had his door open
apparently that's the crime
and this is what happened because my
doors are open i want to understand
look if you don't want to you don't need
to sign it i know you're recording me
that's fine i'm allowed to record you
i'm going to give you a copy then you're
giving me a ticket because my doors are
open sir
the charge is crowded out here there's
nobody sitting in the restaurant
everything is okay giving me a ticket
because my doors
are open what if my store is hot i'm not
allowed to open the door because the
store is hot
everything's spelled out in the summons
i'm gonna give you a copy
and i'm gonna leave can i have your name
please
is is it in the report but it's not fair
that
only because my doors are open and i'm
getting a violation
you know i'm struggling here every
single day it's hard for me
and there was nobody inside the store
obviously because we don't have dining
we only have takeout there was nobody in
the store
and i'm only getting a ticket because my
doors are open
uh can you just please repeat that
sentence while i'm getting a violation
is because i was upper i'm operating in
a red zone
with what what is that in the red zone
uh you're only supposed to do pick-up
and delivery at the door everything's
spelled out here in the song so
but i'm doing pick up a delivery when
the guy walked in i told him to step
outside that was not good enough
[Music]
i'm not here to argue i'm just recording
that's
enraging obviously uh the the and you
want to talk about being unified and
bipartisan
if that's possible all this should be
bipartisan rage it's something like that
i don't know what that business owner's
politics are doesn't matter to me
it's completely insane it's it's hard
enough
if you're if you are a restaurant owner
you know this or in many other
businesses too
um hard enough to stay afloat
but when you have local government
officials local little petty tyrants
coming in
trying to make it even harder for you
completely arbitrary reasons you had the
door open
so what what's what's the fear here that
uh that
you know he has a coronavirus and it'll
somehow escape from the door and float
down the street and attack somebody
what what what is the fear what's what's
the worst case scenario keeping the door
open
in what way is that going to contribute
to the
isn't it better to have it open have air
circulation
speaking of which speaking of not having
air circulation
this is at a different restaurant also
in new york
a new innovation here you can see bubble
dining
so we've got people who are sitting
outside you know
outside of a restaurant at a table but
they're in plastic bubbles
and this again is is the flaw one of the
many flaws in the do
something approach that i talk about
this this restaurant
figured that we got to do something
if something's better than nothing oh
we'll just put them in bubbles no no
in fact it's not better than nothing
nothing would be a lot better in this
case
because now rather than people eating
outdoors with lots of air circulation
where the risk of transmission is very
low
now they're in a very tight enclosed
space with other people
sitting and talking for extended periods
of time the waiters have to enter the
bubble
to take the order and presumably the
next group of people
are going to be in that bubble too
so some of the particles ejected by the
one group will still be floating in the
air and then someone else gets into the
bubble
another group oh yeah but i'm sure i'm
sure the you know
the wait staff will come and spray it
down with a little lysol that'll kill
everything that'll be fine
so this you you could not think of a if
you were trying to come up with a way
like a mechanism by which to transmit
the coronavirus
you couldn't think of a better way this
is a very efficient coronavirus
transmission
um device is what they've come up with
in the name of
protecting people from the coronavirus
when they could have done nothing
and just let people eat outside or you
know what even eat inside
you're going to put them in bubbles why
not just put them inside
number three a new biden ad played
during a game one of the world series as
a side note
i just now learned that the world series
is happening so that's
that's interesting uh this ad is getting
some buzz people saying it's a great ad
tell me what you think
[Music]
there is only one america
no democratic rivers no republican
mountains
just this great land and all that's
possible on it
with a fresh start
cures we can find futures
we can shape work to reward
dignity to protect there is so much
we can do if we choose to take on
problems
and not each other and choose
a president who brings out our best
joe biden doesn't need everyone in this
country to
always agree just to agree
we all love this country
and go from there i'm joe biden
and i approve this message now it is a
good ad
uh bad products often have good ads
case in point on occasion you see a good
pepsi ad
even though it's a terrible product but
if you actually understand what's
happening in our country and you're
clued in
the ad is also slightly creepy like
something from an alternate
dimension because the side that's been
stirring up riots the side that calls
the opposition nazis the side that says
america is systemically racist
white males are toxic racists uh the
side that's you know hunting down
chris pratt because of of he didn't
attend a biden fundraiser
this is the side now that we're getting
this unity and togetherness stuff from
oh and the side that that protest the
national anthem
tears down our monuments spits on our
historical heroes
chance america was never great
wants us to agree that we all love this
country and go from there
i wish that were true i wish we could
agree on that that'd be great if we
could agree on that
we obviously can't i wish everything in
this ad were true
but it's not it's a fable it's nonsense
designed to dupe
the credulous and the ignorant and it
just might work
unfortunately number four there's been
outrage over a police officer in miami
who apparently was at a polling station
in full uniform wearing a trump
2020 mask the police chief issued a
statement
about it and then also the mayor of the
city
held a press conference about the police
officer in a mask
we were made aware of a police officer
who was wearing a
political face mask while in city of
miami police
uniform the department has confirmed
that the photograph was taken while the
officer was in line to vote
the city of miami and the miami police
department do not support or endure
endorse any candidate for political
party or elected office
the involved officer was not authorized
to wear a mask with a political
messaging
nor was he given any administrative
direction to support a particular
candidate or political party
his actions have violated departmental
policy and he will
be disciplined it's it's inappropriate
it's a violation of departmental orders
you know police officers are supposed to
be impartial so irrespective of
who the person was whatever sign it
would have been um
it would have been problematic and
something that uh
that we cannot condone and we do not
accept and so
he's going to be disciplined for it now
yes cops shouldn't be publicly
supporting
a candidate while at a polling station
in uniform
or no matter where they are if they're
in uniform they shouldn't be expressing
political views
true but also get a grip
did a cop's face mask really require a
damned press conference
you'd have a press conference over that
of course the claims online this is
voter suppression voter suppression
how's it voter suppression
didn't stop you from going to the polls
what are you going to show up at the
polls you see a cop and a
biden or a trump face mask and when you
get scared and run away
come on and i don't blame this cop for
doing what he did shouldn't have done it
i don't blame him their lives are
literally on the line here
democrats like biden are out spreading
the outrageous myth and conspiracy
theory
that the cops are are hunting and
murdering black people of course not
true it's getting cops killed
democrats also want to defund the police
biden thinks that cops
should have to shoot dangerous criminals
in the leg
so they're openly taking the side of
violent criminals
they don't care if cops get killed so
instead of asking why this police
officer is wearing that mask
maybe ask why he feels so strongly about
it
that he would risk his career to wear it
that to me is the more relevant question
here number five finally um
it has long been known that a sequel to
one of cinema's great masterpieces is in
the works space jam 2
starring lebron james gonna be released
in 2021 sometime uh i assume
now i'm skeptical of the sequel already
for a couple of reasons first of all
lebron james is a propagandist and a
phony who casually stokes riots and
racial tensions so that's an issue for
me but also
space jam the first one was one of the
formative
films of my childhood and i think it
features some of the most emotional and
affecting scenes
uh you'll see in any film when jordan
emerges from the
from the cartoon spaceship at the very
end and uh
on to the the the baseball diamond to
the sound of r kelly singing
after winning a basketball game against
aliens who are trying to enslave bugs
bunny and daffy duck
that's one of those moments in film that
sticks with you and molds you and shapes
you
uh can the sequel live up to those
heights well the synopsis has leaked
apparently this is from ben meckler on
twitter who's apparently a director and
writer himself
he says this is a synopsis of the new
space gym
during a trip to the warner brothers
studio nba superstar lebron james and
his son accidentally get trapped within
a world that contains all of warner
brothers stories and characters
under the control of a malfunctioning
all-powerful force named aig
played by don cheadle with the help of
bugs bunny lebron must navigate through
a never before imagined world with
iconic movie scenes and characters
as they reassemble the looney tunes to
rescue his lost son
now to get back home lebron and the
tunes have to unravel aig's mysterious
plan and win an epic basketball game
against digital gamified super versions
of the nba and wnba's biggest stars
as the entire world watches that's
apparently the uh
that's that's the synopsis a few issues
here number one
the wnba's biggest stars do you mean
like biggest as in physically
because the wa nba doesn't have big
stars at all
in any other sense so that's a problem
also
mainly this just sounds like a lengthy
elaborate commercial for warner brothers
and their other brands and properties
which is what it is
of course and what most big movies are
these days
speaking about marvel every marvel movie
is
really just a long toy commercial that's
the only reason it actually exists
the marvel movies they exist to
propagate themselves like a virus
and they exist to sell merchandise they
don't exist to tell stories which is why
they don't really bother with a story
they just tell the same story over and
over again
uh that's all this movie is too but
still
looking forward to it i'll take my kids
to it uh that's
that's the excuse i can use to watch it
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation
today we're going to cancel birthdays
all birthdays with a few exceptions
which i'll explain but the catalyst for
this the final straw anyway was this
tweet from camila harris on tuesday
wishing herself a happy birthday
accompanied as a gif
of camille harris laughing and shaking
maniacally now i have to say
perhaps the most camila harris thing in
the world is kamela harris wishing
herself a happy birthday with a gif of
herself
looking like a serial killer in the
middle of an epileptic fit now camila is
65
56 years old this is a 56 year old woman
fishing for happy birthdays i wish i
could say that she was
uniquely perverse for this i mean she is
uniquely perverse in so many ways but
not for this
i am horrified constantly to find grown
adults
talking about their birthdays
celebrating their birthdays
throwing birthday parties for themselves
often i'll i'll be around someone and
they'll drop a hint usually the hint is
something subtle like
it's my birthday at which point i'm
supposed to i guess throw confetti in
the air
weep with tears of joy but instead i
usually say something like
oh and then they then they just walk out
of the room offended and scandalized
that i didn't congratulate them
for the monumental feat of existing
because that's what you're saying think
about what you're saying to a person
when you tell them it's your birthday
you're saying hey you know not trying to
make a big deal of it or anything but uh
i i exist yeah i know you exist i can
see you no no you don't understand
today completes another year-long cycle
of existence for me
so if you're an adult and i'm
interacting with you i already know that
you exist
and i i assume you've existed for
several years at least
the fact that the earth went around the
sun 42 times since you were born
is arbitrary and also uninteresting to
me
you may as well run up and demand a
party because you've seen
983 squirrels since your birth or
because you just tied your shoes
for the twelve thousandth time at least
tying your shoes is a minor achievement
celebrating your birthday
is to celebrate you regardless of what
you have or haven't achieved
i don't know if you've done anything
worthwhile in the last year why should i
celebrate the fact that you've
lived all year you could have even done
great evil with your life
for all i know think about this and it
should be enough to put birthdays to
rest
hitler had birthdays dozens of them
so if you're now turning 27 well
congratulations even hitler did that
in fact i find it rather suspicious that
hitler had birthdays and so do you
what else do you two have in common now
here's another thing to consider about
birthdays
i believe they're discriminatory in some
ways against people
in the much maligned unenthusiastic
community
which of course i belong if you're
naturally enthusiastic about things then
other people's birthdays don't present
much of a challenge someone says
it's my birthday and you respond oh wow
that's amazing i'm so excited or
whatever it is you say see i couldn't
even do an impression of it
without sounding sarcastic that's
because i am not an excitable person
and i'm especially terrible at feigning
excitement about something banal and
boring
and birthdays are the most banal and
boring thing in the world and i simply
don't know how to pretend
that i care which puts me in an awkward
spot it's not fair to me
worst of all is when someone close to
you like a family member is having a
birthday or a friend
but they don't live with you so now
you're expected to make the dreaded
birthday phone call now as has already
been established this week
phone calls are abhorrent in the first
place a birthday phone call though
that is my hell that's it my hell is
just birthday phone calls me making
birthday phone calls for all eternity
i never know what to say the
conversation usually goes like this me
hey just calling to say happy birthday
other person oh thanks thanks thank you
so much
me so uh you were born 31 years ago huh
wow pretty wild
other person yeah yep getting old
me ha yeah birthdays
what are you gonna do birthdays hmm
what's that i'm breaking up click that's
basically every birthday conversation
i've ever had
and my family's starting to get
suspicious about the conveniently timed
bad reception that always happens on
their birthdays and just to be clear
about something i don't make exceptions
for myself i don't care about my own
birthday either my wife
my wife cares she cares about all
birthdays she cares enough to cover me
and half the block
and she'll always ask me on my birthday
she'll say hey what do you want to do on
your birthday
then i'll say uh well i have to run to
the dry cleaners
we could do that get some rbs on the way
back
that's never elaborate enough and then
she'll give me a really thoughtful gift
something really wonderful and creative
and nice inevitably the only gifts i
actually use though are whiskey fishing
poles and socks and that's it
and that's the way my birthday goes so
here's the here's the
the rule from from from here on out
children can have birthdays birthdays
like marshmallows and cartoons
are really for children mainly we should
grow out of them as adults
but if you make it to triple digits then
i think it's acceptable to start
celebrating birthdays again unless you
start
unless unless you're still kicking it
like 109 or 110 or something
at which point like we get it you're
just showboating now so relax
and at that point i think the birthdays
have to be withdrawn once again so
from the ages of 1 to 18 you can have
birthday parties
from 19 to 99 you may not then from 100
to 109
you can start celebrating again under my
theocratic
fascist regime i will allow anyone in
the non-birthday time frame to submit
to submit like a waiver along with a 900
fee requesting special permission for a
birthday party
i will allow that because i am kind and
merciful
but for the most part for most people
uh birthdays are officially canceled
we have enough holidays enough gift
giving occasions stop being greedy
and selfish just wait for christmas
until i get around to canceling that too
don't put it past me
that'll do it for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
the doj moves to break up google the fbi
confirms hunter biden's emails are not
russian disinformation and a former rnc
chairman endorses joe biden check it out
on the michael knowles show